é gostar desse desafio de pensar o
próximo passo
nós estamos um pouco dar um passo atrás
imagine uma viagem no tempo até o ano
500 de cristo tem como nacionalmente que
é o fundador do islão é essa
o último dos profetas com os outros
temos que ter uma presença me por
exemplo há sempre essa referência às
áreas não na nossa história
avançamos um pouco até a função da
península ibérica é é a presença nos
muçulmanos também é visível à justiça
por todo lado né
a relação de portugal com uma nora e
animação na centenária numeração nós
usamos hoje em olinda é um merece sara
língua portuguesa está recheada salavdor
engenharia não é isso
o algarve anos avançado espanhol começa
por alba e uma série de derrotas nessa
obra souza alfa coxa
o fogo era o mesmo e vai da região de
fátima não é que é a primeira filha de
maomé era nada temos pelos seus gols de
flores da região
é este ano comemoramos o centenário av
esta é a referência que as visões luz
fátima era de alguma forma uma herança
da presença dos aliados naquela zona
estamos novidade pra mim hoje
assim ele precisa sempre é ao mesmo
tempo neste discurso
houve também sempre prescrição e
fanatismo não é portanto sopas do idade
média e já costas fronteiras definidas
não é a inquisição ea perseguição às as
outras funções no caso até foi sobretudo
judeus que serão obrigados a sair do
país o ananás cristãos-novos portanto a
este seu nome é completamente
desconhecidos pensarmos um pouco sobre
isso quando chegamos à imprensa apenas
nos comandos é você é um outro é sempre
o desconhecido não é sempre aquela que
nos ameaça sempre que eu tô crise é
fácil for num total do mal
chegados à a assuntos sérios nem eu sei
com 21 aqui a cimentar carreira dos
atentados terroristas
novamente nos aparece o islão e os
muçulmanos como o fio a ameaça o outro
quer me que ameaça europa mais de 50
dias com três dos refugiados nem pessoas
que podem se estão em guerra e que não
tem como conviver com você não bota os
criatórios disto como acontece em que se
tornar um filho nos facilmente acessar
contatos há desde o ano passado com a
campanha da nova presidência isto muitas
opções ainda maior né não são mães foram
tomados persona non grata na nos estados
unidos é e ao movimento que este
fenômeno a uma a 15 evento reações nem a
tentativa de construir um pouco essa
idéia de colocar sempre o outro os
problemas e foi nessa altura que surgiu
uma campanha que não virá a única não
circular um pouco lá todas as redes
sociais chamava-me da amazônia era
muçulmano e era um um vídeo muito
engraçado
é que os trava há pessoas contavam que
era um ice mas família meus filhos o que
faziam gostava de fazer que eram médicos
professores às crianças perguntavam por
que é que eu estava a usar o mouse e nós
somos jornalistas não é portanto é bom
sobretudo porque em portugal a uma
comunidade até já bastante
representativa nos romances estima se
que cerca de 50 mil 135 mosquitos e e
outros locais de culto e estupram a
fundação aga khan por exemplo que hoje
vou assim a vencer uma delas foi que é
uma série de dinheiro para as vítimas da
droga 500 mil e agora pra ajudar a
construir a nova lei iria tentar aqui
uma cheia mais ligações e enfim outras
outros olhares e outras posturas perante
os acontecimentos e precisamos também
fazer o aplicar a campanha internacional
aqui em portugal como os humanos que
vivem cá exibição portuguesa e lá é não
tenho 25 anos o psicólogo criminal
trabalho com um motor dos aviões nasci
em moçambique
os meus avós eram minha sofreu me quer
não fui eu que decidia a gente colocar
toda a vida em 19 anos só do futebol o
consultor na área de saúde que trabalham
em prol o sabe que por causa também
jogador de futebol se a crianças de 3 e
o meu cartão de visita é muitas vezes é
sempre foi fulano eu fui karla costa até
a partir de 10 de janeiro de 2015 paz e
se acham mohamed sim sou muçulmana
surpresa quando eu menos de 1 e de um
nome é quererem paulo e as pessoas dizem
mas você nem parece um ser humano eu
preciso dizer mas o que é preciso é
muito mais emoção é bom eu gosto e temos
como base a paz
segundo amigos da família são várias
vias congestionadas
o equipamento com as árvores por exemplo
uma escola eu não posso comer tudo
porque não posso comentar por causa da
religião um substantivo e chegou a
cobrir se não cojo católico e respeito
kanter surjam cada um deve respeitar tem
uma namorada portuguesa branca
nós cada vez mais somos uma uma nação
sem fronteiras não é apesar de algumas
alguns pães crer agora começar a pôr
fronteiras e não faria por muros e
ergueremos gosta de discutir sobre o que
fazer diversos temas seja religião ou
seja a cultura geral seja pessoal do
tranco tenha um fim neste momento é
estarmos se nos estados unidos no texas
temos uma não vai ajudar na guerra quem
fuma não vai colocar bombas em si e
destruir seu cinto cada vez que há um
atentado
as coisas pioram sela ward do paraíso
sou um grande fã da cozinha portuguesa
nós cabrito assado no forno
nos meus tempos livres eu gosto de
cuidar de animais gosto do usuário com
chuva na cara pois não temos que nos
tempos livres
a agora como na cabeça que hebe winters
nós estamos mais que as nossas crianças
nós somos mais do que os muçulmanos são
um serviço mais sou um som mais humana
estou tomando são mais solução eficaz
que se dizer que eu fui contando então
esse filho o pai somos mais só os
funcionais
[Música]
é não sanchai no fx gum copa copa e
pronto e é isto que eu confesso que para
mim mesmo que melhor sobre essa pena
carregar no poema mas agora quero me
desconstruir o que foi fazer lá pra
cuidar dessas pessoas nem que também
representará sem pouco dos dízimos
sentimos a necessidade de que quero
desmistificar um criança do do sul mal
em tamanho e em portugal
então entrei na empresa que também já já
trabalhava com essas questões há mais
tempo foi ter com uma das representantes
aqui em portugal com maior ativismo na
comida
ian e através dela tentamos recolher o
maior número de pessoas que fossem sim
pra eles entendem margem mil e ainda
temos dois dias de estúdio nível
portuguesa tentará em 2012 mas crimes os
retrogenes das mais diversas áreas de
actividade das mais diversas idades com
o troféu todos os tipos e e menos 15
pessoas há um nome que percebemos que
era realmente a gestores tenham também a
necessidade de mostrar o que quero estar
aqui e passar uma mensagem então a certa
altura tínhamos muito mais do que o
tiraria dela também quer participar a
limo prime ea tia de um vôo e as coisas
não podem ir lá já não conseguimos estão
fazendo aí as coisas muito curiosas não
é o davi psb do futebol que parece é que
passa vai diretamente do treino do
sporting em alcochete e foi jogado por
onde jesus fez questão de estar presente
ainda gostar
depois é isto tivemos realmente se não
soubéssemos a partida com 10 muçulmano e
isso é também um desafio que os propõem
quero olhar é lembrar algumas das
pessoas a não ser aquela a escala costa
não é que neste caso até o contrário
tinha uma burca esperança o brasil com
ela e uma possível queda muçulmana mas
do resto dificilmente
agora terceiro na dançarina na primeira
que trabalha com filmes e castas animais
que é lindo ver novelas exato e e pois
este trabalho foi também fazemos das
questões mais banais
- algumas questões como chamas do neto é
o que gosta de comer e e que gosta de
ouvir é e outra coisá que eu posso dizer
a um ano que a irmã goiás aqui o tipo
divertido termina o vídeo a cantar pelo
its quando ele comandava a galera o
músico estava mais é o desvio de septo
fire e movimento é movimento era uma
banda que eu não conhecia mas já
culminou a minha admirador e precisa da
música eletrônica com um pouco de
movimento por segundo
concretamente foi pesquisado e está
imenso hoje o icms a banda e ainda
vivemos gol eu vivia usada civic é um em
londres com seu amigo - é quase
impossível a pessoa não se identificar
com o que sai daquela mãe que tem um
filho está no texas nem só os dos
estados americanos é maior portanto não
só estava esperando uma coisa mais
incrível tendo em conta já ufa
os olhos das crianças aqui magníficos
mas realmente é e nós com nossa região
qualquer aquelas pessoas e acho que o
próximo passo é essa em casa todos os
dias
sim cada um individualmente contribuir
para essa inclusão será não só concorda
comigo trazendo combinando desta página
não é só porque era de facto podemos ser
nós né
selecionamos kan não somos nós que
fazemos são mais do que suas crenças de
pessoas conscientes que estuda na escola
católica
isso é é sinal é o fundo também pouco o
tempo nós somos os recolhemos é que
incluímos e clique que o próximo passo
que o mundo vai fazer crer
[Aplausos]
[Música]